[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with ali mirage columnist at the article
and jasmine cameron chaleshi political
correspondent at the financial times
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now
the financial times leads with the
expected applications by finland and
sweden to join nato after russia's
invasion of ukraine in what it calls a
geopolitical shift in europe
and after ukraine's victory last night
in the eurovision song contest the metro
reports the country's president is
insisting next year's show will be held
in kiev
the telegraph leads with a warning to
the eu from boris johnson that the
disagreements over the northern ireland
protocol are holding the government back
from taking action over the cost of
living crisis
that's also on the front of the express
which reports the prime minister saying
there will be a necessity to act if
brussels fails to reform the northern
ireland trade rules
well according to the eye ripping up the
agreement risks sparking a trade war
with the eu
the guardian has news or morale between
police leaders and the home secretary
over what's described as a power grab to
allow her to intervene in local matters
and silence criticism from forces
the sun goes with the queen's 70th
jubilee celebrations and how actor tom
cruise got the celebrations off to a
flying start at windsor
and the weather is on the front of the
star which says storms are on the way
and then a heatwave in june
and a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
programme you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we are joined tonight by ali mirage
and jasmine cameron celestio good to see
you both um let's start with the
telegraph the front page um to do with
the northern ireland protocol and boris
johnson uh it's saying as reported here
set to scrap parts of the the protocol
ali
well look it's extremely worrying julian
that uh this gives the impression that
the uk cannot abide by its international
agreements which it
took ages to agree
over many many months this was designed
by lord frost in conjunction with uh uh
his opposite number on the other side uh
and this is where we ended up and now we
want to drive a coach and horses through
the whole thing uh which will not only
uh damage our international reputation
it will also
potentially put the good friday
agreement in jeopardy as well the
reality is if you're going to try and
protect the integrity of the single
market on the eu side and protect the
integrity of the uk on the other those
things are mutually incompatible there
was always going to have to be a border
somewhere and the compromise reach was
so that border would be in the irish sea
now that was uh didn't go down well with
the dup at all they thought that they
had um been thrown under the bus and
they have
and this is causing serious problems
particularly now since shin fein is the
largest party uh following the recent
elections but this tough talk is really
damaging at this time we really need a
trade war with the eu like a hole in the
head with inflation where it is in the
cost of living crisis and frankly it's
tough talk at the end of the day if
legislation is brought forward by the
government to renegon parts of this
protocol it's going to have to go
through the lords it's going to be stuck
there and the eu will take legal action
who knows how long that will take
and yet this uh change in the the
protocol
looks almost inevitable now
jasmine
yeah so we're hearing that this week it
looks like um the government's gonna try
to introduce um
new legislation to try to override parts
of the protocol obviously johnson has
set out the uk's position and his
comments been widely briefed and
trialled in the telegraph and other
papers now they want to sort of make
clear that they are willing to override
parts of the protocol but at the same
time leave open the negotiating
solution you know negotiating hands the
eu and i think we're in a really
difficult moment because actually as ali
was saying there is a huge risk that our
reputation is really damaged by this and
that it creates the impression that we
are a country that was willing to enage
on agreements that we put forward and
sign and this could have all sorts of
implications for our relationship with
the biden administration and parts of
europe and you know notwithstanding that
the risk of a potential trade wars you
know
is is increasing so we're at a very full
period at the moment and if we do see
the introduction of legislation as we
were just discussing there is a
possibility that you know there's a
crash in the commons there's a backlash
awards that we're really seeing months
and potentially years of brexit
wrangling all over again
yes and the eye pointing to the the
trade war the suggestions that that is
the the next stage if the protocol is um
overridden in whatever form ali
yeah well look amaro sefkovic the vice
president of the uh
european commission has been very very
clear these discussions have been going
on for months now uh and liz truss is uh
clearly playing hardball on this uh
presumably the motivation is partly to
position uh for a potential leadership
contest if and when that arises to try
and endear uh oneself to the tory right
but this is a lot more important than
trying to win leadership battles quite
frankly um and then on the other side
you've got simon coveny and then the
irish t-shirt saying that they don't
want to be collateral damage in a
ongoing dispute between the eu
and the uk the reality is that if the uk
wants to play hardball on this it can
but then the risk of this is there's
going to be a border at some point the
irish are going to have to potentially
erect a border if they're going to stay
in the eu to protect the integrity of
that single market that puts the whole
entire good friday agreement in jeopardy
and we were hearing about julian if you
remember all these technological
solutions that we're going to
miraculously appear from somewhere well
it's been years they haven't come
forward and now boris johnson is saying
to us that that the eu is preventing uh
dealing with a cost of living crisis
because of the northern ireland protocol
so they can't give the same vat
reductions they give on the rollout of
solar panels on your house or ground
source heat pumps i mean really come on
let's get real
jasmine what hopes do you have for his
um last-ditch attempt to resolve this
his visit to to northern ireland
i mean it's not looking i'm not feeling
particularly optimistic given that this
is a combination of sort of months of
back and forth over this matter but i do
think from johnson's perspective i mean
there are many reasons for this to not
end up in new legislation and there you
know there's a real i think desire to
actually find another solution to this
given that there's a lot at stake here
and also i think the government will be
very conscious that this is an
administration that came into power and
was elected on the premise of quote
unquote getting brexit done but if you
think back to 2019 there's all this back
and forth over what brexit meant and how
it manifests and johnson really
as part of his pitch to the public said
you know we're going to get this matter
over the line we don't have to be
talking about it anymore and actually if
we are facing months and potentially
years of back and forth over this matter
i think it will really chip into the
credibility of the government i mean
it's pointed to vaccines and brexit as
the two things that it's done in power
so far and if it ends up that we're back
talking about brexit back to square one
i think johnson will be very conscious
of how that will play out in the eyes of
the public we'll just move on to the
metro um actually before that let's go
to the financial times their front page
and uh nato and this is the
uh membership of finland and sweden in
the the making and perhaps the complete
opposite result of what vladimir putin
was hoping to achieve ali
that's exactly right so finland and
sweden are
sort of overturning uh decades in the
case of sweden 200 years of
military non-alignment to seek to join
nato uh it's not clear whether turkey
will um provide its support but it
certainly is indicated that it won't
stand in the way and this is all on the
back of um vladimir putin's invasion on
the 24th of february of ukraine i mean
you can argue whether it was right for
nato to flirt with a ukrainian
membership going back over well over a
decade and what that was what was likely
to do in terms of russian perceptions
but it's clear that putin's
aggressive act and raising of cities to
the ground and killing indiscriminately
of civilians uh has led to this uh
action
and certainly uh the problem we now have
is uh what does a piece look like we've
heard increasingly tough language from
our own prime minister about the fact
that putin must be seen to fail and the
question i've always got around this is
uh what does failure look like what does
success look like and i heard from um
interesting comments from the great
granddaughter of nikita khrushchev who
is uh the russian premier in the
standoff in 1962 with kennedy in the
cuban missile crisis and kennedy was
very conscious to allow christian for
faith-saving way out and the question is
here if putin's digging in and there's
sort of talks about even now tactical
nuclear weapons maybe being deployed
which is horrific even the thought of it
how do we actually
manage ourselves down from this cliff
edge that we're all on at the moment
yeah that very uh key question uh there
uh jasmine that uh ali is asking and
also we've heard from uh president putin
quite bellicose language and that those
that are joining nato um it's a a big
mistake and there will be retaliation
i mean the reasoning behind the decision
um made by sweden and finland to sort of
you know declare their intention to join
nato is very clear it's obvious that you
know situation has been escalating in
the ukraine conflict they'd obviously
looked around and thought well perhaps
we'll it's better for our national
security interests we are in alignment
with nato but the big question for me is
actually does this make europe safer or
does this actually a
because as you said president fusion has
been very clear about what his red lines
have been when it comes to extending the
membership of nato and i think the
question for me is that obviously this
is even if they've declared um sweden
and finland have declared their
interests it's not an overnight process
this will take time to get accreditable
nato members and so what happens in the
interim of this weird grey area where
the two countries have declared their
intention but they're not yet members
and i think that would be a question
that you know western leaders will be
mulling over in the next few days and
weeks yeah indeed and trying to find
some light in all of this uh president
zielenski is vowing to hold the next
eurovision song contest in ukraine as
they won last night
tally uh that's right they won with
their track uh stephanie which was
partly euro pop partly rat partly
football chant with a chorus and partly
flute riff with quite a catchy flute
riff as well so you know good for them
uh it's great that they were supported
and
look i think president zielenski has
been leading from the front he's a
comedian by background but he's risen to
the challenge and he is winning the pr
war he's spoken at the grammys he's
spoken to the uk parliament the u.s
congress and he really is championing
his people and showing great courage and
fortitude uh and you know
congratulations to ukraine for winning
and he's saying that uh uh next year it
will be hosted uh in ukraine and
hopefully one day in mariopol
they did of course uh pip sam ryder to
to the position um jasmine but i don't
think anybody's complaining are they
no i don't think so and i think it was
the result that we all wanted people
sort of watched the conflict play out
from afar and i think there's a real
sense of wanting the underdogs to win
and wanting a win for ukraine and as i
think was saying i think president
celente has really shown that yes
obviously it's a ground conflict but
there is an element of he's been very
good at reaching out to western leaders
western countries as i'm saying getting
on the grammys sort of really putting
forward the you know ukraine's case for
the rest of the world
jasmine and ali thank you very much for
the moment we're going to take a break
coming up
who's still got it in for margaret
thatcher
intrigued stay tuned
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview still with me ali mirage
columnist at the article and jasmine
cameron chuleshi political correspondent
at the financial times let's have a look
at this story on the front of the daily
telegraph and just some more detail
about the buffalo gunman new york state
who killed 10 people some more detail
coming through about his manifesto of
hate jasmine
yeah i mean it's really horrific what
we're seeing emerge um out of the us um
today and it seems that um around london
city khan was
list of individuals named by the gunman
who on his you know his basically his
hit list um and you know it's very clear
now that the attack was racially
motivated and there was a sense of
the
individual in question wanting to take
as many um
lives of ethnic minorities as possible
um and i think there will be a lot of
questions being asked of the u.s
authorities um particularly as it sort
of seems like he was on their radar i
think there are seen some reports that
he had actually um he had threatened um
another shooting in the past and so i
think there'll be a lot of questions as
to
what you know whether or not he was on
the radar of the authorities and what
could have been done to prevent an
action taking place and i think there
are you know
there are going to need to be broader
discussions about again the issue of
racism and and what can be done to
eradicate the the beliefs and the
viewpoints that that
wound up in the shooting that we've seen
yes and also uh issues yet again about
uh the gun laws in america ali
it's depressing uh jillian i mean what
what can one really say
is this truly surprising i mean how many
more of these things do we have to see
year after year after year between 1968
and 2017 1.5 million americans have died
as a result of gun
oh we've lost ali there i
don't think he's going to
no he's he's not coming back
oh we've lost both of them have we
yes we have we've lost oh you're back
ali you left us for a moment you were
you were giving us some very horrifying
um stats sorry jillian
obviously obviously the broadband line
was disgusted by the fact that 1.5
million americans have died since 1968
to 2017 this nonsense continues i
understand americans have got this
this deep-seated desire
to have the right to bear arms right but
when you mix that with mental health
issues in this case blatant racism and
we're going to see what happens in the
investigation here but it it looks like
it was completely racially motivated you
wrote a 180 page dossier uh um
and live streamed the whole thing it's
like how many more of these things have
to happen for americans to wake up and
say enough's enough i can't see when
it's going to change so frankly all that
we're going to be doing is hearing
president of the president condemning
this nonsense this horrific violence and
nothing's going to happen yeah it is
very depressing president biden
describing it as a stain on the soul of
america we've just got time jasmine to
talk about the margaret thatcher statue
in grantham on the front of the daily
telegraph
yeah so this is basically a statue that
was put up in grantham which is um
the late um prime minister um thatcher
obviously had links to the area she had
um that's why she grew up where she went
to school um so there's a statue that's
been put up and it's basically been
egged by protesters and it's in some
ways inevitable that when you have a
political figure who inspires both love
and hatred on either side that
that statue would be a target um but
it's striking that it happened so
quickly i think it only been up for i
think a couple of hours and it had
already been been targeted
very quickly ali one sentence any
surprise
one of the greatest prime ministers of
uh the 20th century and i i you know i
wonder what she would make of the policy
of leadership on both sides that we have
right now
ali and jasmine thank you very much